lovesick Head Over Heels butterflies in
the tummy we all have ways of describing
what love feels like but what is
actually going on in our brains when we
fall in love and how do we know how to
distinguish lust from Love
[Music]
according to Helen E Fisher from Rutgers
University there are three aspects of
romantic love orphan loss comes first
but not always
for some people who are asexual it may
not happen at all but for those who do
experience lust it's driven by the
hormones estrogen and testosterone they
affect our libido the sex drive it may
feel purely carnal but in fact it's
about the urge to mate and pass on your
DNA via Offspring with Outlast it's fair
to say our species would not survive
the second aspect of romantic love is
attraction influenced by a
neurotransmitter called dopamine this is
a feel-good substance released in our
brain that is involved in driving us
towards reward do something get a
dopamine head feel good eventually
dopamine will push us towards repeating
that behavior this is why intense
attraction feels like an addiction to
another human being
some people get stuck in that Loop
always chasing the dopamine-soaked
excitement of a new relationship
might as well face it you're addicted to
love
dopamine also dampens the region of the
brain that regulates critical thinking
and rational Behavior people often stay
in the support of rational honeymoon
period for up to 18 months
another hormone that plays a role in
attraction is norepinephrine which is
involved in generating the physiological
responses we experience in this state
think sweaty Palms heart fluttering
breathing faster
in that sense strong attraction is
similar to a state of stress but it's
good stress because we associate these
Sensations with positive things such as
the sight sound or even the smell of our
lover
the third aspect is attachment or
bonding there are two other hormones
that work here oxytocin
and vasopressin
oxytocin known as the cuddle hormone is
released during sex and skin to skin
contact this heightens feelings of
security and contentment which help
forage deep bonds with a mate in some
people negative experiences as a child
can affect the oxytocin system making it
harder for them to form attachments as
adults but thankfully with the right
kind of therapy our brains can be
rewired to form healthy relationships
as for a vasopressin this is released
directly after having sex and it too
produces feelings of contentment this
may have a teeming effect on more
promiscuous people by triggering the
neural reward system encouraging you to
want to stay with the person you love
and all being well with time love can
morph into something stable and
fulfilling research has shown that
kindness plays a key role you could say
that a long-term bond is a continuous
exercise in kindness of course love can
also have a darker side
obsessive jealous behaviors can be
intensified by Falling levels of
Serotonin a mood leveling hormone and we
all know that love doesn't always last
and when it doesn't it hurts heartbreak
is real it's known as broken heart
syndrome and can even be mistaken for a
heart attack the emotional stress that
accompanies breakups releases chemicals
that usually signal physical pain so our
brain interprets the breakup as
intensely painful but despite the
heartbreaks the sweaty palms and the
irrational Behavior people fall in love
and stay in love every minute of every
day because those dopamine hits can feel
amazing so even if it doesn't always
feel like it the head really does rule
the heart
foreign
if you enjoyed that be sure to check out
these videos next and if you haven't
already hit the Subscribe button and
click the Bell to get a notification
each time we upload a new video